やばい　最近全然ツイッター読んでねえ
読みます！！
ｵｵｫｫｫｫ　なんだよこれ
感応式信号から来てます
京都って感応式信号あるの？
あると思います！
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
・・・
久しぶりに文房具でもやりますかぁ！
って言うのも
４月！
学年が上がった方も　卒業した人も　入学した人も
社会人始まった人も
いろんな人がいると思いますが
えー、皆さん……
勉強の方いかがでしょうか
いやマジで最初の方はやる気出ると思うんですよ
新しく学校入ったりとか
学年上がったりした時は ちょっとこう、
勉強のやる気が出るんですけども
だんだん徐々にこの
4月の終わり頃にかけてくるとやる気がなくなってきて
そのまま五月病になってしまう
ケースがよくあると思うんですよｵ！
五月病になる前に
ちょっとこの気分を一回入れ替えて勉強できるように
あの、
おろ！？！？！？
って思った面白そうな文房具を
ちょっと 5種類！ 準備いたしました
僕も最近 地味に書くことが多くなってきたんで
ちょっと文房具欲が上がってきたんで
ちょっとこのタイミングで
皆さんがちょっとでもやる気になるような
ステキな文房具見つけてきたので
紹介していこうと思います
すげーいい動画！
5種類あるんですけども
まずはこちらです
ペンケースなんですけども、、、
ラベルうぜ〜
あー、でも取りやすい
ラッキー☆
あー！あぶねえ
スタンドペンケース
これちょっとまって　これすごいんですよ
めちゃくちゃ これ使えるんすよ
ちなみに、ぼく今 使っている ペンケースは
このペンケースです
ｼﾞｨｨｨｨｨｨ（チャックを開ける音）
歯が付いてます
あれ 俺これ何年 使ってんだろ
もうたぶん5年ぐらい使ってるんすよね
YouTube はじめた頃から使ってるんで
5 年ぐらい 多分 使ってると思います
長い間 ありがとよ…
中身 は 結構 普通 なんですけど、
あ～
こういう感じの　普通の中身なんですけど、
例えば こうやって普通にペンを 入れますう
まあ もちろん こうすると
普通に ペンケースとしても 使えるんですけど
すごいのは ここからっす！
開けますう、
ここのくぼみが ちょっと気になったと思うんですけども、
これを～？
床に～？
叩きつけると～？
あーら びっくり！！
ペンスタンドになるんです
これはまじで 便利だと思いました
なんか筆箱って、わざわざなんか ペンとる時に
こうやって開けて なんか ゴソゴソするのが
めんどくさいんですけど、
ペンスタンドだったら
もうこのまま、こうやっておけるんで　机の上に
ほしいペンがあったら
あぁっと…キャップ……
ほしいペンがあったら すぐ,こうやってチェンジできて
このまま使えるっていう 動作の速度が
すごい僕は 魅力的だな って思いました
ｷﾗｰﾝ☆（ドヤ）
はい、次は こちらです！
Say goodbye to paper...(セイ グッドバイ トゥ ペーパー)
紙に さよなら って 言ってます
・・・
これ すごい良さそうでした
まぁ 簡単に言うと
だと思ってもらえれば いいと思い ます
ノートでも ないんだな なんか
メモ帳 みたいな感じ だった気がします
でもな～、なんか 厳しい学校だと
こういう 電子機器 持ってくだけで
怒られたりしそうだから ちょっと怖いんだよな
あい、こんな感じでぇす
ちょっと やってみましょう
後ろにペンがついてるっ
えっ　えっ……
おわっ！きてる きてる きてる！
こういう感じで なんか 字が書けるわけでございますよ
わっ
すげえなんかタッチ感がマジで字書いてるみたい
まって！ これマジで凄いんだけど！！
やばい、 なんか、
ペンタブ、 ちょっと書きにくいのかなと
思ってたんですけども
これ 本当に ノートに文字書いてる感覚と 超似てました
え、すごい！ マジで 感動してる！
トメ ハネ ハライ まで 綺麗に写ります
んで　真ん中押すとリセットされるんですけど、
これ、ちゃんと横に ロックボタンが あって、
ロックをちゃんとすると、 真ん中のボタンを押しても
消えなくなるんだと 思います
ﾊﾟﾁｯ(ボタンを押す音)
エェー！！！
続いてこちら
最近 シャーペンの紹介をあんまりしてなかったんですけども、
ちょっと良さげなのを見つけたので 買いました！
MORRISさんの push pushっていうシャーペンでございます
amazon で買ったんですけれども、
カラーバリエーション が 結構ありました
で、これ、 何がすごいかと 言いますと、
ちょっと あけてみます
この 基本的な この上をノックする 出し方 と、
あと あの よくある フルフル！ 振って出す 出し方 と、
横に ボタンが 2つ付いてると 思うんですけれども、
ボタンを 押すだけで シャー芯が 出てきます
あ～いいですねえ
めっちゃ 書きやすいです
結構 ペン先が 鋭くなってるんで、
図形用のシャー芯(？)のたぐいになる と 思い ます
あの、グラフとか スマッシュとか あっちらへんですね
なんか 無駄がない感じで すごい書きやすいです
あの、これ、
いいっすよ！
シャーペンで書いてると いかに速く シャー芯を出すか
と、いうか 結構 大事な ポイントだと 思うんすよ
そういう時に、
あの～、
いろんな 出し方 あると思います
なんか ノックが基本 なんですけど、 ノックする時って
この 書いてて ノック に 構えるまで
だいたい 0.5 秒 ぐらい かかるんですよ
その 0.5秒が もったいない！
その分、振る時だったら こう、すぐ
って 振れるし～、
でも振るのってね、周りの人に 迷惑かかるんですよね
ちょっと、こう、
腕の振り がちょっと ウザいというか
こう、なんか 周りから 見ると
みたいに ちょっと 引かれるかもしれないので、
書いてて ボタンを 押すだけで、 すぐ シャー芯が 出るので
一番 無駄 のない シャー芯の出し方 なのではないかな と 僕は 思いました
それに 人によって シャー芯の出し方って
こう、個性が 出ると思うので、
あの、ボタン 押すの嫌な人もいると 思います
そういう人のためにも
やっぱ フリフリ でもいけるし、
ノックでもいけるし、
万人に 対応した、
素晴らしい シャーペンだと僕は思いましたッ…
続いて こちらァ！
ちょっと 僕も よく分かんないです
面白そうなので 買っちゃったところが ある
あ、 でも、ベスト セラー 1位です
えっと、この エルフィンノート ってやつは
繰り返し 使用可能な ノートです
ほぉ～　すーげえ
なんか
なんか永遠に 使えるノート らしいですね
あー でも 普通の ノートだ
ノート自体は めちゃくちゃ かっこいいっすね
おしゃれな ノートです
中に ちょっと いろいろ 説明が あります
とりあえず 電子レンジ でチンすると
中身が リセットされて
もう1回、 使えるらしいです
え、でも これ
フリクション だからじゃ ないんですか？
フリクション だから 書いたら 消える 的な やつだったと 思うんだけど
んで、なんかすごいのがー、
書いた 中身は データ化 できるらしいんですね
きれいに
おーすごい！
一瞬で 超見やすく データ化 されました
なんかノートとかって、 カメラで撮るとー、
なんか 粗い じゃないですか
めちゃくちゃ 綺麗に 鮮明に 映りまし た
スゴ！！！！！！
何回も 使い回せるノート。
そして 内容が データ化されるので
なくなる心配もない。
・・・
時代やなぁ……
こんなノートなかったもん　俺の時代！
はい、そしてラスト こちらでございます
なんか これほんと
興味本意で買ってみたんですけどもお、
らしいです
そんなペンあんのか って思ったんですけど
買ってみました
うわ…中がなんか………s……
うわっ えまって これ
初期不良的な～？
へこんどるやないかぁぁぁぁい！！
やべえ　いきなりストレスたまっちゃった
へこんでるから 開かん
開いたっ！！
おぉっ！
これが ストレス解消するペン らしいです
何これ　普通に書けんのかなぁ？
んーまぁまぁ そこそこ 書きやすいです
なんか 両方 ペン先が 付いてて、
赤と、黒 になってます
これ すごい なんか
気合で ペン先が 収納できるんですよ
こうやって………
あれ！？ これ ひょっとして………
すげー！！！！
ペンなのに ハンドスピナー になった！！！
おぉぉぉぉ　すげー！！！！
これだったら 授業中は ペン回し が できるんで、
確かに ストレスの 発散に なります
おぉ！！！　すげー！！！
こいつぁ すげえや
って 使わねえよぉぉぉぉぉ！！！！！
《エンディング》
ﾀｰ ﾀﾀﾗ　ﾀｰﾀｰ
ﾀﾀﾗﾀｰ ﾀﾀﾗ ﾀｰﾗｰ
ﾀﾗﾗﾀｰ ﾀｰﾗﾗ
ﾀﾗﾗ ﾀｰﾗｰ
ﾝﾀｯ ﾝﾀｯ ﾝﾀｯ ﾝﾀｯ
ﾝﾀﾀﾀﾀｯ♪
と いうわけで、 あの～
文房具 とか ノート とか そういうのって
すごい モチベに つながると 思うので、
五月病に 負けないように
頑張ってくださいっ！！！！